quantum mechanics is supposed to be our
best theory of physics that's because it
can tell us what will happen in any
experiment that we've tried but science
is also meant to explain why things
happen quantum mechanics doesn't give us
why because we still don't understand
how to interpret its meaning at all for
example when an object starts at a and
ends up at B does quantum mechanics say
that it goes all possible ways at once
or that there are many copies of each
object in many different universes each
going a different way or does it say
that it doesn't even make sense to talk
about something when we're not looking
at it these are all possible ways to
interpret quantum mechanics at least on
face value in this video we're going to
look at the basic rules of quantum
mechanics to understand why its meaning
is so evasive
[Music]
we're about to look at an experiment
that showed that nature has a very
strange rule objects act differently
when they're not being measured before
we get to that though we need to
understand when objects are and aren't
being measured so let's look at this
familiar situation you've lost an object
but you're sure you left it either here
or here you're not currently measuring
its position yourself because you're not
looking to see where it is however
consider that there are many other
things that are measuring it for example
think of all the light particles
bouncing off it right now they're
essentially taking a photo of where your
object is what about the air molecules
that would have gone straight through
where your object is if it wasn't there
but are now bouncing off that position
they're also measuring your particles
real position and that's how it usually
is objects are constantly being measured
by other things so then this statement
that objects act differently when
they're not being measured doesn't apply
for everyday objects which is why we
didn't notice this rule for such a long
time but then scientists started to look
at very small things like electrons
things like air molecules and light
aren't constantly hitting them because
they're small enough to sort of fit in
the gaps so what exactly do objects like
that do when no one is watching let's
get back to the scenario where our
object so in this case our electron is
definitely in this spot or this spot
but we now know that nothing is
measuring it we expect that objects can
only be in one place at a time even if
you don't know where that place is you
know it's in one of the places you just
don't know which and this is usually
true but in the case where nothing at
all is measuring our object like our
electron the following experiment will
show us that this isn't true the
electron can't be at one place at a time
while it's not being measured
this experiment is called the double
slit experiment and here's how it goes
we're going to fire electrons one at a
time from here when they get to this
back wall it's the place where the
electron hits lights up how do we make a
wall that lights up on contact with
electrons the physics is a two-step
process first find one of those clever
experimentalist people and to ask them
to use their experimental physics magic
to help you simple the point is we know
where the particle starts and somehow we
measure where it ends but in the middle
we don't measure it and hopefully
nothing else is measuring it either then
put in a barrier with two tiny doors in
it obviously there's a good chance that
an electron fired towards this barrier
doesn't make it but we're going to
ignore any that don't get through the
electrons that do get through must have
gone through via the doors we'd expect
that it went through one of these doors
it's just that we don't know which one
but we'll see that while the electron
isn't being measured by anything this
isn't the case it doesn't go through a
single door to show this we're going to
predict where the electrons would have
landed if they acted as we expected and
see that it's different from the actual
result of this experiment to get our
prediction we need to know what an
electron that definitely went through
only one door would do so let's close
one door and actually do this experiment
as you can see electrons going through
this door end up in a pile behind the
door and of course if we had done it
with the other door open instead then
similarly electrons would end up behind
that door in a bunch so if we know an
electron goes through one of the doors
then we know approximately where it will
land
now say both doors are open and we
predict each electron has to go through
one door we're going to make sure that
the electrons are fired slowly enough so
that different electrons can't go
through together and then interact with
each other
now we predict that some of our
electrons will go through this door
but we know electrons going through this
door end up here because that's what
happened in the single door experiment
and similarly others will go through the
other door and end up here so if each
electron goes through just one door then
we must get two piles and yet this
prediction is completely wrong we have
to conclude that the electrons didn't go
through just one door each but I know
what some of you are thinking then they
must have gone through both in other
words the electron quite literally gets
cut into two part of its mass goes one
way and the other part the other way
then these two parts of the object bump
into each other causing them to ricochet
wildly and the weird pattern or in some
versions of this explanation the
particle splits into two and then
flattens out into two waves that
interfere with each other unfortunately
there are many problems with these sorts
of explanations firstly if it splits
into two bits or if it spreads out then
when you measure it at the wall you'd
expect to get two dots or a spread out
smear that's not what happens though one
electron through gives you one crisp dot
but some people believe a more
complicated version of this wave story
to get around this that goes it's a wave
when you're not looking but when you
measure it it becomes a particle again
that would mean that as soon as the
electron hits the back wall it has to
immediately pick up all of its mass from
everywhere it's spread out to and gather
into a particle again but moving mass
around takes energy where's the electron
supposed to get that from
there is a sense that waves are involved
in this experiment but it's much much
more subtle than you may have been led
to believe anyway the point is the
double slit experiment showed us some
important things where nothing watches
what an object does it doesn't just do
one of the options we can't see that
directly but we can infer that from the
experiment and the object doesn't
physically split up and have parts of
itself do each of these options so what
exactly is the object doing behind our
backs and how are we supposed to predict
the results of this experiment they're
crazy and it isn't just the double slit
experiment that had unexpected results
by the way loads of other experiments
showed that particles are doing
something really fishy when we're not
looking and that's why scientists
invented quantum mechanics it's some
nice maths that you can tell an
experiment to and it tells you what you
can expect and so far it's always been
exactly right which is a grand
achievement but we still want to know
what's the particle actually doing but
this quantum mechanics doesn't tell us
it's just a bunch of maths after all in
fact some physicists say that it doesn't
even make sense to talk about an object
that isn't being measured that it
doesn't exist this seems crazy to me and
thankfully to many others too recently
more physicists have started to tackle
this question again and they've even
started to tease meaning out of this
mathematics amazingly by using more
mathematics it's a really exciting time
to be asking questions about this theory
that's why I'm making a series of videos
on quantum mechanics the first set of
videos will teach you the rules of
quantum which are mathematical but
they're really not hard and you don't
need any background in maths or physics
already to understand them
after that we'll cover fun topics
including quantum computing eventually
which is what I'm doing my PhD on when
the next video is up you can click here
to see it feel free to subscribe if you
want to know when that happens meanwhile
you can try these homework problems to
see how much you understood from this
video write your answers in the comments
if you'd like I read them and it helps
me a lot to understand which bits were
the trickiest first question we talked
about doing the double slit experiment
with small things like electrons but is
there any reason in theory that we
couldn't have done it with bigger things
and what would you need to do to make it
work second question we didn't measure
where the electron went in the middle of
the experiment but it is possible and so
if we were to measure each door to see
which one the electron went through what
would we find and what would happen to
the pattern on the back wall finally
there is another way to interpret the
double slit experiment which I think is
really cool
it's called pilot-wave theory and I've
made a video about it in that theory the
particle goes through just one door even
though our argument said that that's not
possible find the floor in our argument
also comment on why particles still act
strange in the pilot-wave theory I hope
you have a go at some of these questions
and ask anything that you didn't
understand below I'll see you in the
next video of the understanding quantum
mechanics series
you